resident before remake is only weeks
away but there are still so many
questions to answer about capcom's
ambitious remake who the hell are you
thankfully I got the chance to see about
20 minutes of gameplay which gave me a
glimpse into the lake area the castle
and the iconic krauser knife fight here
are 11 new things I learned about the
game knife Perry Galore chainsaws aren't
the only thing Leon can deflect with his
trusty knife now in fact from the
gameplay I saw you'll be able to Parry
just about anything with your knife
whether it's torches thrown at you
arrows or even a nasty tentacle Claw
from head erupted parasites
Leon's knife has been given a hefty
upgrade in functionality but of course
not without some compromises unlike the
original the knife now has a durability
bar akin to Resident Evil 2 remakes take
on the knife so while the extra
versatility adds more variety to
residential 4's combat formula it's not
without some Resource Management
considerations a additionally Leon now
has the ability to evade fatal blows
giving the player a split second prompt
to dodge attacks like the garador's
enormous claws expanded exploration
while the original residential 4 was
rather linear in its presentation at
least by Resident Evil standards that is
the Remake is taking a more expanded
approach giving the player more space to
wander and explore areas off the beaten
path more notably the freedom to explore
by motorboat in the original driving the
motor boat was limited to the Del Lago
boss fight otherwise using the motorboat
prompted a load screen between areas
this time however you'll be able to
control the motorboat freely traversing
the watery depths of caverns and
exploring other areas entirely many of
these areas seem to be gated off but can
be accessed by solving small puzzles
similar to the Insignia puzzle seen only
once Outside The Village Church in the
original
an additional detail I noticed during
these motor boat segments is that the
prompt to ready Spears exists beyond the
Del Lago boss fight leading me to
speculate that there are more enemies to
fight in the water than we've been shown
new requests a staple of the original
was the blue Medallion side quest where
players could scout out and shoot blue
medallions hidden in the environment to
unlock special weapons to purchase from
the merchant this time around the
medallions aren't the only things you'll
be hunting for Leon will now find a
multitude of requests such as finding a
golden egg and selling it to the
merchant in an interview that I did with
the Capcom team that couldn't share what
other requests there will be but they
assured me that there will be a variety
Beyond just shooting medallions and
hunting for X storage new to Resident
Evil 4 remake is the addition of storage
a staple and many other installments in
the franchise but emitted from the
original re4 whenever Leon visits a
typewriter the player can now store
their items using a storage option this
is significant considering that if you
ran out of room in your case in the
original you'd have to sell or abandon
those items which sometimes meant
parting ways with weapons too I suspect
the implementation of storage came in
part with the addition of crafting as
players will now be collecting a lot
more items in order to make herbs
ammunition Etc and this is sure to lead
to a cluttered and overstuffed inventory
quickly case customization and charms I
loved nothing more than spending an
exhausting amount of time organizing my
inventory in the original game which is
why this new edition is a good one
players can now change the physical
appearance of their case it's a small
but considered touch that acknowledges
the importance of the game's system I
was only given a peek at two of the case
Styles a traditional Silver medal and a
more sleek black exterior while not
confirmed I can only imagine that there
will be many more options to unlock the
exterior of the case isn't the only
customizable Edition Leon can now attach
up to three charms to the case each one
with their own gameplay a perk I was
shown a chicken charm which granted the
player a hundred percent Health when
eating an egg now Capcom told me that
these charms are unlocked by playing a
mini game but the details of that game
were not disclosed could it be a
replacement for the figures you unlocked
from the shooting gallery minigame in
the original time will tell plaga can
now attach themselves to the ceiling Yes
you heard that right the already
terrifying claga that erupts from
cultist's head can now leap into the air
and attach to the ceiling which is
utterly terrifying this I think is a
welcome addition considering the amount
of combat versatility that leonow has
with the ability to sneak as well as
Perry attacks so seeing this terrifying
display is only welcome considering how
much more Leon can now do in combat
compared to the original Ashley Graham
among the many overhaul scenes so far in
residential 4 remake one of the most
interesting has of course been Ashley
Graham self and based on the eight
minutes of gameplay I saw with her she's
been significantly reworked in some
inspiring ways most notable is the lack
of a health bar no longer will the
player have to monitor her health stop
the game to give her herbs or worry
about upgrading it along the way instead
when Ashley is injured she'll become
incapacitated requiring the player to
get her back to her feet by interacting
with her now considering these changes
of course I had to ask Capcom whether or
not you will be ordering Ashley to hide
in a dumpster but they confirm that that
will no longer be the case emphasizing
that it's unkind to treat the character
that way another change is how Ashley is
commanded the player now has two basic
options for Ashley which are either to
give Leon some space while in a fight or
to stick close to him give me space okay
this is a welcome change as the commands
feel much more organic and natural than
in the original which were just simply
wait or follow me some things are best
unchanged while there's a considerable
amount of tweaks and changes some areas
appear nearly identical to the original
notably the entrance to the castle
making your way into the castle taking
out cultist's arm with bow guns and
dodging an onslaught of flaming
cannonballs seems almost unchanged from
the original but not without some small
upgrades that is including the ability
to freely fire a cannon at other
catapults enemies and of course the main
entrance gate new weapons bolt thrower
joining the Arsenal is a bolt thrower I
only got to see it in action once during
the gameplay but it was used to launch a
proximity mine in the ground before
exploding and knocking several enemies
back considering the new crafting
mechanics I speculate there will be a
variety of ammo types to make for the
bolt thrower which is reminiscent of
Resident Evil Code Veronica's bowgun is
this a nod to Code Veronica probably not
but that doesn't stop me from convincing
myself it is the garador fight there are
many iconic enemy encounters from the
original resident before but few are as
embedded in my brain as deeply as the
first run-in you have with a blind and
unwavering Beast that is the garador it
was a claustrophobic dance of tiptoeing
around the Monstrous brute who could
only track You by sound in the remake
Capcom has upped the ante by making the
arena in which you fight it even smaller
and with the addition of chains that
dangle from the ceiling forcing Leon to
maneuver around them to avoid making
sounds and giving away his position this
new take on the fight was also one of
the first times I got to see the benefit
of the newly added stealth mechanic
which showed Leon sneaking up and
stabbing the beast in its back
The krauser Knife Fight quick time
events are officially a thing of the
past yes that's right the original
testosterone-induced action-moving Knife
Fight executed solely with QuickTime
events has been overhauled to a
full-fledged real-time fight sequence in
the short clip I was shown the game's
knife pairing mechanics and Split Second
evade prompts were on full display while
duking it out with Jack krauser while
I'll always have an affinity for the
original qte Knife Fight the one in the
remake still manages to look totally
badass also it appears the conversation
between Leon and krauser has been
fleshed out more with Leon calling out
operation Javier could this be more
details of explaining Krauser's supposed
death that happened two years prior we
shall see and there you have it after
all it's only a few weeks until
residential 4 remake finally comes out
and we get to have some of these
questions answered with that said stick
here at Gamespot for the review when it
comes out alright thanks for watching
until next time see ya